good morning or good afternoon everyone
and welcome to our webinar stem cell
derived exosome production
in steep tank bioreactors this webinar
is part of our virtual event eppendorf
planet of knowledge
here on lab routes following the webinar
take your time and have a look at our
event platform and discover more content
and workflow solutions for your research
my name is david loeb the moderator of
today's session and now let me introduce
to you my colleagues aurelie
and pogba who will present their work on
exosome production
in steer tank bioreactors to you and
with this i will hand over to
hover yeah thank you david
uh hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar entitled stem cells derived
exosomes
production in stereotype bioreactors
uh this is the agenda that we prepared
for you today and we divide in
three main topics first the introduction
i will discuss about some as a promising
cell free therapy tool
then we will discuss about the challenge
behind exosome production process
the second process i will describe
process development
in that box many parallel reactor system
and then at the end i will explain the
existing production on siberia between
by reactor
control system yeah
as everybody knows stencil therapy also
known as regular medicine
is designed to repair damaged tissue the
human body
by implanting new other stem cells
modulating the immune system
and reducing inflammation the promise of
stem cell
uh this therapy is to help the body to
heal
itself increasing the quality of life of
life for patients
so you can see here more than five
thousand
clinical trials have been reused for
different
applications the global essential market
is very competitive nowadays an estimate
to reach around 146 million dollars
but 2024 this market is fueled to
the therapeutic action of stem cells for
cereal disease treatment
and because of the stem cells line
banking
in addition to that the development can
be used for important stem cells ipsc
also has contributed to the growth of
this market due to the social ethical
issues as shared with embryonic stem
cells
as you can see you can see here in the
picture of them
that disorder segment during the global
stem cell therapy
but unfortunately clinical trials uh
have
uh made only a modest improvement in
restoring normal functions
the relative tissues
in the early days the mechanisms of
action of the cell therapy claimed that
cells implanted should integrate in the
site of injury
replace the damaged tissue and improve
tissue and organs
however limitations associated with cell
localization and cell survival
in the target issue works against peace
regeneration
but the real question here is do we have
the right tool
to address this to address the cell
therapy limitation
let's go through that external vesicles
including exosomes
are one of the most important para clean
effectors
involved in the intercellular
communication
they were discovered more than three
years ago and they were considered as
cellular west disposals
uh think of an exosome as an embryo
with instruction inside like one cell
male in a letter to another one
telling me what to do in this case the
envelope that is the exosome cargo
contain micro rna non-cooling arranged
and a lot of proteins
they are released from difficult types
uh
such as t and b cells mesenchymal stem
cells steel cells
as i mentioned before they mediate inter
and intracellular communication
when they are secreted in the blood
stream and also they emulate the immune
regulatory processes
set up tumors k mechanisms and mediate
renative or
the herniated process
uh they have also around shape
morphology
and they are present in the priority of
body fluids such as blood
urine amniotic fluid synovial fluid
etc the cell cycle form consists of
extracellular vesicles
specifically some micro vesicles
membrane particles
peptides and a small protein so you can
see
here uh uh which is this this picture
because we have
you know a comparison between them but
you know exosomes are
lipid believers basically with a
diameter ranging between 50 and 100
nanometers and also they can easily
confirm by suffers
such as cd9 series c3 cd81 of
the transparents
yeah but not all the synthetic derives
and
derived exosomes are similar
the mesenchymal stem cells are present
in in different adult pieces such as
alipon tissue bone markers or umbilical
cord
as well as apse and embryonic
stem cells and depending of the source
there is some yield
is completely different so they offer
several advantages compared to the
cell-based
approaches including exceptional
stability
and biocompatibility moreover they can
be delivered to target fisa easier
than the whole cells and they can
migrate across the
blood-brain barrier
according to the pubmed and you can see
here in the slide
the number of citation has grown more
than 10 times in the last decade or so
have
gaining importance today this new cell
free therapy
has had a big impact in various fields
of application
finishing 192 clinical trials worldwide
related to episodes that are listed in
clinicaltrial.com
so they have been used as drug delivery
systems
as tumor biomarkers and mesenchyma
extensor derived exosomes also have
great potential in bone
and calves regeneration
this figure showed the biotherapeutic
particle history since
2006 so as you can see here
in 2006 was approved the first cancer
vaccine
later in 2012 uh was approved the first
gene therapy
and in 2015 was approved first
oncolytic biotherapy products
oh and now i will let my voluntarily to
describe the challenge
behind exosome production process thank
you jorge
now you have a clear view of what's on
exosomes
and their growing interest in the
context of cell-free therapy
nevertheless
the exosome production process is still
challenging and the pre-clinical and
clinical development of the exosome
technology as a cell free therapy
or drug delivery platforms we cry large
quantity of exosomes
it's really difficult to define a
precise range
regarding the optimal therapeutic dose
indeed this therapeutic dose will depend
on the specific purpose of the study
and on the way the exosomes are
quantified but you have here
an example of the huge quantity of
exosome which is required to be
administered to an animal to achieve
biological outcomes so the mass
production
of exosomes is then a requirement to
generate a
clinically relevant amount of exosomes
however the mass production of exosomes
presents several
challenges indeed you have to reach
a delicate equilibrium between the
quantity and the quality
and the final product must be pure
but also keep its biologic biological
property
the manufacture process you have to use
should be scalable of course but also
have to be controlled
standardized in order to improve
reproducibility
and finally this process should be in
accordance with the appropriate
regulation requirement
so for the moment the most current
methods used to enrich collect and
isolate exosomes are not fitting with
those
aspects the exosome production workflow
is a multi-step process and could be
divided in three major step
the upstream process here first
during which the cells used as exosome
sources
are expanded and also during which the
exosomes are enriched in the cell
condition
medium the second step is the downstream
process
consisting in the isolation of the
secreted exosomes from
others element containing the condition
medium
and finally the quality control which is
based on the exosome characterization
and for all those steps um
all those steps could be a source of
variability and a challenge for
the researcher and for example for the
upstream process the question of the
researcher could be
which exosome source to select or
how to ensure an efficient cell
proliferation and exosome suppression
how to deal and how to proceed to the in
process control
so before to go more in detail with the
upstream process which is the topic of
today
i would like to briefly describe you
some challenging aspect and key message
associated with the downstream process
and the quality control
there is a large variety of techniques
which could be used to isolate it
hexosomes
historical gold standard methods are
based on ultra centrifugation
with two main variation either
differential palleting or using density
gradient but in a manufacturer point of
view
the ultrasound ultrasound certification
based methods
are present some limitation especially
because
they are difficult to scale up the
process is often long
multi-step and require high level of
skill
and expensive equipment so
it exists a lot of different order
techniques to isolate exosomes such as
size exclusion chromatography
filtration-based method
precipitation or immuno
affinity capture those methods present a
better scalability
but all those methods present advantage
are a limitation of course
main uh iris here is some
some important message to consider from
for exosome isolation strategy
and selection especially in the
transition from a bench scale to a
clinical production of exosomes
so first of all a very important message
that is that
for the moment there is really a lack of
standardization for the exosome
isolation strategy
nevertheless the isolation strategy you
choose will
will greatly impact the final product so
it's really important to keep this in
mind
another point is that often researchers
will use combined techniques
in order to improve the purity of the
final product
with a balance between recovery and
specificity and
the choose of the technique the truth of
the strategy to combine
together to to to isolate your exosomes
will really
really depend of the final purpose so
that's
the once again the question of the
balance between the recovery and the
specificity
in the context of mass production of
exosomes in a therapeutic
purpose the crucial aspects to keep in
mind are
of course scalability respect of
regulation
potency maintenance of the final product
process control
but also specificity and high efficiency
in terms of yield
cost and time so it's really really
challenging
regarding the exosome characterization
there is also very large variety of
methods used
making results and analysis really
difficult between
difficult to compare sorry between uh
study
from from a study to another so some
methods are based on physical properties
others are based on the presence of
specific markers
and recent review also highlight
emerging techniques
but once again there is some challenge
especially the standardization
the specificity the sensitivity and the
throughput
of those methods and now we will focus
on the first step of the workflow
so the upstream process resulting in in
an efficient
exosome succession we would like to
highlight key factors to address to
improve
and warrant a successful and
reproducible upstream process
so as jorge mentioned in the beginning
of this introduction
not all exosomes are the same not all
hemisc derived exosome are similar
during
uh it's really important to keep in mind
that the cell culture parameters used to
improve and to to process the cell
expansion
will largely impact the quantity and the
quality of the secreted
product and the secreted exosomes so any
change
in the cellular phenotype due for
example to
the adhesion process the proliferation
process or to
any potential uh cellular stress
occurring during this
this phase of the culture could and once
uh could generate unwanted alteration in
the composition and the function of all
those exosomes
has those two very interesting uh
interesting articles
um describe
so of course uh you could consider
different parameters which could impact
it could be the culture medium the
culture support
but also other physical chemical
parameters
regarding the culture medium
the idea is to push an efficient and
robust cell proliferation of course to
do that
we usually use growth factors generally
supplement
in the medium as a fatal bovine serum
but nevertheless those animal-derived
supplements contain
exogenous exosomes which could cause
contamination in the final product so
exosome collection could be then
consequently performed differently
either either using um
culture medium supplement it with
exosome depleted
fbs in order to reduce the the
the potential contamination take care
that it's not a free
of exosome medium but exosome depleted
it will just reduce the contamination
another way it's to use a two-step
process
with the first phase which is which
answer the cell expansion in a classical
culture medium
as soon as you have obtained an optimal
cell density
you will completely change the medium
for an exosome collection medium
which is free of exogenous medium in
this medium the cell will decrease the
proliferation
but you will use this medium for a
reduced period of time
just to collect the exosomes some
commercial versions of those medium
exist and
are supplemented to increase the exosome
suppression
another important parameters is the
culture support
especially in a scale-up process so
conventional 2d adherent cell culture
support
such as flask or multi-layer flask are
limited
in term of growth surface area per
volumes
so usually we go in the direction of the
3d culture especially based on the use
of macro carriers to increase the cell
density
using a bioreactor and
this culture in 3d could offer
not only the advantage to be scalable
but also the advantage to be more
physiological for the cells and
different papers have has already
described the fact that
the the use of a 3d culture could
improve the yield and the functionality
of the secreted exosome
in the transition for the 3d culture
there is a lot of parameters that you
have to
to optimize you know in order to ensure
a robust attachment and
an uh an efficient start of
proliferation
among those parameters you could of
course select the most appropriate
type of carrier the initial self-seeding
density could also be optimized
as the cell carrier denser ratio
and you could also optimize the first
period of time
in order to improve the adhesion with a
reduced agitation for example or using a
reduced volume
finally there is a lot of different
physical chemical parameters which could
impact your culture and you have to take
care to the ph
the oxygen tension the temperature
maintenance the agitation
and of course the feeding strategy you
will use
as an example here in order uh to be
more physiological you could be
interested to reduce the tension of
oxygen
in order to be more physiological
mimicking the in vivo niche of the stem
cells
and all those parameters should be
stable
and more sorry could you moot
thank you
in this way the use of stereotank
bioreactors could be very interesting
and offer you
a lot of advantage those uh
bioreactors um
[Music]
allow you to process um to monitor and
control your process
during all the entire process you could
really control and find the ideal
condition maintain those conditions
during
all the process and nevertheless
moreover they propose a scalability
option
with a similar vessel geometry and
capability at different size
so it's very interesting in in this way
as a conclusion of this introduction
we would like to insist on the
importance of the standardization
of the entire process through all this
process from the cell culture
to the final characterization and it's
also very important
to really describe in detail the
material and method part
of the publication in order to be really
reproducible
and to reproduce exactly the same
condition
in the next part of the the presentation
we will introduce you the use of the
deathbox mini
parallel bioreactor system to develop an
exosome production process in a small
scale tire
tank bioreactor and optimize the culture
condition
before a potential scaling up
so this first slide uh described here
the experimental strategy used for the
upstream process
so mscs derived from adipose tissues
have been selected as an exosome source
after towing the cells will recover a
few days in a flask
the appropriate amount of cells have
been
seeded on microcarriers in a bioblue
single used vessels
and the cell grow is then monitored
during five days
by the dust box systems growth sectors
are headed
three days post seeding in order to
improve to ensure proliferation
monitoring of the cell adhesion but also
the cell variability
is performed during the expansion phase
after a five day of cell growth the
culture medium has been completely
changed for a collection medium which is
free of exogenous
exosomes and the exosome enrichment
occur during two
additional days at the end before our
vesting
and performing downstream process
here are the main process parameters
used during this upstream process
you have here the type of carriers and
the quantity we have used the
inoculation cell density
and the working volumes importantly we
have
note here the cell carrier ratio and the
dissolved
uh oxygen percentage which which
correspond to a
pressure of oxygen of eight percent
mimicking the in vivo environment
we have also the ph and also information
about
uh different parameters such as the
agitation
we have the agitation for for the first
four hours and then the agitation was
set
at 100 rpm during all the process
here are the first results cell
viability was determined
regularly during the process by staining
with a fluorescent
calcine am probe and visualized
under a fluorescent microscope as you
can see through the five
days prosthetic cells are growing
progressively and form progressively
small aggregates
and 3d structure the proliferation has
also be evaluated through cell counting
perform
a different time point during the
process so small samples of the cell
suspension are taken from
bioreactors and cells are detached with
trypsins
and count it with a visceral automated
cell contour
the result obtained confirmed the
efficient proliferation with a very
short
luck phase at the beginning and the
final density is note here
you have here the complete the
the total number of cells in the vessels
which
and the fall increase we have obtained
after five days
in the meantime we have also checked the
concentration in glucose and
concentration in lactate
which are liber liberate it's created in
the
in the culture medium and those
parameters also confirm that
the proliferation is efficient
now here is the experimental process
used for the downstream part
we have collected of course the
self-conditioned medium
and this medium has been centric huge
filtrate and
concentrate using those parameters
a small sample is
safe to perform particle size
distribution analysis
and the rest of the volumes is load on a
size exclusion chromatography colon we
collect at the n22 fraction
and the total protein content is also
evaluated during all this process
at the end every fraction is
concentrated before to be submit to
exosome characterization and in our case
we have select
to study the the presence of the cd63
protein a transmembrane tetraspanning
protein
which is specific of exosomes true
thanks to an elisa approach but also
with the western blood approach
negative control it's really important
was also performed
in parallel it consists in a
non-condition
medium so it's the the collection medium
without be
with no contact with the cells and this
negative control
um as follows exactly the same procedure
the same process
than our conditioned medium
here are the results obtained with the
elute fraction
uh using the elysee and the total amount
uh a pro count so in blue you have the
total amount
evaluation in all those fraction
and you can see that there is a peak
here on the
on the fraction 20 21 and 22.
in parallel we have also the result from
the elisa essay
and here you have seen that we have a
peak uh
on the top of the fraction 18 and 19
with a maximum of quantity in the
fraction
19 corresponding to 9 to 10
um exosome quantity
we confirm this those results with the
western blood analysis and here again
we have an increase of the cd63 protein
in the fraction from 16 to 20
with a peak at the fraction 18 and 19
17 until 219.
finally we evaluate
the size distribution of the samples we
have collected
through two different methods the
dynamic light scattering and the
centrifugal liquid sedimentation
analysis
once uh those two methods confirm that
we have a population or a b model
distribution with two neural nearby
population
uh at size ranging in the the
range of the exosomes so
to conclude this part of the
presentation
we can say that the dasbox mini reactors
is a perfect tool to test and optimize
the process at small scale
you can really compare and
test the influence of different culture
parameters
during all the process it's really easy
to compare
you you could monitor every physical
chemical parameters
in a very stable environment in order to
define
reproducible parameters to reproduce at
the end
so now i would like to let jorge present
another and different strategy in order
to produce exosome in the psi
barrier
thank you yeah
so a different strategy following this
story
in this case as you can see here we use
bioluminescence single-use
vessels as bioreactors for uh induced
important stem cells that are mesenchyma
stem cells
exosomes uh production isolation and
characterization
we employ the siberia between bioreactor
control system
as a controlled device and calling
called micro carriers
as uh so crucial support support the
main
aim in this story was the production
of autosomes using one liter scale as a
model
for large scale production in
bioreactors
to demonstrate the ability of ipsc
derived mesenchyma stem cells to create
exosomes we perform two uh medium
exchange experiment in four steps
as the picture show
yeah in the step number one a detailed
inoculation the
preparation we use typically we use
fifth cultural conditions
for the initial expansion and hyperflash
in the third process to achieve the
appropriate inoculation cell density
then the stainless capacity of ipsc
derived mesenchymas themselves
was analyzed by flow cytometry noting
that
they displayed typical phenotype of
mesenchymal stem cells
possibly for cd90 and cd29 typical
mesenchymal stem cells market and
negative foreign markets such as cd
34 and then for monocyte
111d
so then ips drivers in china tell us
where transfer into a glass bottle
containing the
collagen called micro carriers and cell
corrosion medium in this case we use two
different kind of media
ns12 and 80 cc complete million
then we kept the bottles in the in the
incubator for two hours
uh under certain conditions as you can
see here
yeah on the other hand prior to the
preparation
of the bioblue one c one c single-use
vessel
we perform a calibration of the ph
sensor and then
we have fitted uh each blue among others
with
a d2 along with the compressor
adapter both inserted in the first pg
13.5 port on their aesthetic positions
i have to i would like to highlight here
that this big
field was used to do the medians change
following the incubation um
following the incubation 300 cells of
microcarriers were transferred
into the biolu once you have reactor
really filled with
100 milliliters of medium reaching the
working volt
of one liter yeah after
day uh five also cursor we perform
the median exchange every two days on
the day nine
and then daily basis as required uh
but how we did that so we stopped the
agitation and gas flow
for five minutes allowing the micro
carriers
uh to start in the bottom of the biolu
1c
and exchange 10 percent of the medium
using
that dq to remove the cell cursor medium
from the surface
and using the feeding port to add fresh
medium
yeah um after day um
five uh eight at eleven
uh uh day five eight eleven and fourteen
that's closer we collect
50 milliliters of um
years of ips derived mesenchyma stem
cells along with my
carriers and and medium use a container
bag
with uh line set so we transfer that 50
milliliters into
50 milliliter conical two uh along the
aps-c
derived mesh encounters themselves and
microcurrent in the bottom
so then we removed that supernatant and
added 50 milliliters more
medium using the same composition but in
this case replacing the fps
with uh two percent of exosome depleted
fps and then transferred into the the
shaking class
so finally we incubate that iesc drivers
and kind of stem cells
on micro carriers for 48 hours under the
same conditions
so then 48 hours after e-collection day
as you can see here
in this slide and
we removed the supernatant and then uh
we performed the isolation purification
of exosomes according to the exogrid pc
protocol with some modifications you can
see here
so we collected samples every day
in the course of the first experiment
and every two days
in the second experiment from
bioreactors to determine
the cell viability cell density and
metabolic concentration
so three milliliters were collected for
analysis then this
uh a volume will transfer and into the
conical field
so we wash with pbs and then we
drixanize the cells
in order to detach the sauce from the
micro carriers
and uh do the the analysis
so later on the cells uh a microcurrent
work filter through
a 40 micron strainer in order to
determine determining the same viability
and density as you can see here in the
picture
after the cell expansion the cell count
was erratic especially after each
collection day
so we attribute this to the low
inosilation density and also
because we're using the first experiment
the demand f12
cell cursor median whose composition
probably won't be
so optimal for the ipsc derived
mesenchymal stem cells
expansion um also we performed
a second experiment to increase the ipsc
derived mesenchyma stem cells
inoculation density
and the exosome production yield for
each sample so to achieve that we change
the
question media in this case uh we use
apc
complete median uh and also we increase
the inoculation cell
density finally we kept the rest of the
conditions
in the set as phase out of the first
experiment
you can see uh in picture a uh we said
uh uh observed and it's a lag phase 24
hours after the inoculation
followed by the steady increase of cell
growth between
day one and day and day nine so then the
closer reached the structural phase on
day night
followed by a subsequent decrease in the
cell
density until day 15.
i have to to add here that we observe as
essential micro carriers aggregation
later in the course of the run therefore
we base the cell count in the later
stage not only to the floating microcar
only into the floating microcarriage so
probably the average of the cell
expansion and the ratio
must be higher in addition
so we determine the consumption of
glucose production of light states
and ammonia as you can see here in the
pictures
exosomes are highly enriched in protein
in the transparent membrane as i
mentioned before cd
63 9 81 and 82
play a key role in cell invasion
penetration
and solutions events so we use the
direct
enzyme link immuno assays elisa
specifically elijah ultra c 63 ki
in order to quantify the exosome
abundance
the results showed that the number of
ipsc derivements in china
stem cells exosome constantly increased
from day 5
to day 16. so in addition so also we
found
a direct correlation between cell
density and secreted exosomes
during the experiment
it's only the three dimensional uh
dimension of some more
probably include micro carriers we
collect samples at the
five and ninth as you can see here in
the picture
and then visualize them through the
bright field images
so we evaluate the portfolio of human
ips derivation
cells demonstrating that as you can see
uh in in the picture on the left side at
the early stage of the cell
profile a few cells are done on the
microcurrent surface
are progressively formed inter
microcarrier
uh cellular breach and aggregates as you
can see
so it's well known that the 3ds
cellular environment allowed the cells
to mimic the imbue server behavior
involving cell cell and cell
extracellular matrix
interaction and promoted cell signaling
and proliferation so it has recently
been reported that although the
mechanism of
exosome biogenesis is so well understood
finally suggests that the exosome
secretion
molecular cargo can be altered by the
cells
microenvironments it's important to see
to study anthropology
so finally i would like to to add that
these
various training experiments are
preliminary studies
has not just been optimized to obtain
the maximum extras on production levels
however our observations can serve as a
guideline
for further improvement in missing
camera stem cells that are exercising
isolation
purification and scale of protocol
thank you very much
thank you already and jorge for the
presentation
for everyone if you haven't done yet
there's still time to submit your
questions via the q
a window to give you a little bit time
to do this
i would like to show you in more detail
three of our products
that we used for these studies
first there's the salexpert co2
incubator
you do not need to worry anymore to
place your plates always at the exact
same position
because with our incubator we verified
the uniform temperature
throughout the whole system at 27
different spots so
we really ensure that there is a
homogeneous growth condition
the second one um aurelie talked quite
extensive about what was the dustbox
mini bioreactor
system this is a perfect system that
simplifies your process development
it's a four-fold unit but it can be
extended up to 24 bioreactors
and together with a possibility to
easily integrate third-party analyzers
and the combination with our powerful
dustwear software suit
the dust box is the perfect tool for the
efficient process development
and last the saverio twin our newest
bioprocess family member
from the experiments and the results
that hoga did present
the twin controller already supports 19
different vessel variants
and there will be even more to come in
the future
the innovative pay draw concept of this
system allows you to be
to easily adjust it for changing
requirements in the lab
if you want to have more information on
this product you
just visit our website evendoff.comarea
i see now that there are a couple of
questions so
i was to start reading with the first
one and this is
going to hover if i see it correct
the question is how do you ensure that
you do not have exosomes from the growth
media in your experiments
oh thank you david this is a good
question
uh well a critical uh app here has to be
considered
before exosome production and uh
essentially is the cell culture
and we had before
when we were designing this experiment
we
we certainly performed several
preliminary studies to establish
the best conditions you know so one of
them determine the medium composition
so we use medium without fbs and media
with with different
exercises fbs finally we found that two
percent
uh uh is something to be the fbi
sufficient
to man
but you know this is one thing that uh
we
have we have to see in the future we
need more developments of course
uh in order to uh do it for this kind of
applications
okay thank you the second question is
focusing um yeah is for overlea
why are mesenchymal stem cells a common
cell type used in clinical trials to
generate extracellular vesicles
since few years um we know that the msc
secretome
uh paracrine uh factors secreted by
hematis
are described to play a very important
role and have biological outcomes
it could be cytokine chemokines growth
factors but also
evs including microcarriers
including sorry exosomes and
ev derived from mesenchymal stem cells
have been described to have a
different potential interesting effect
such as increasing androgenesis and
wound
repair reduce myocardial
ischemia reperfusion injury
promotes a large variety of tissue
regeneration so
that could be the reason why the msc
thank you overly the next question is
for again
have you compared the results obtained
by eliza with other quantification
methods
uh yes thank you david so yeah we used
three different methods by the exercise
in the berlin we use the micro
the ca holding side to
total concentration and after after
combination
quantified because this
asset gave a better results and logical
exercise
production training
okay i hope everyone could understand
this and the audio connection is not too
bad
the next qua said the next question is
also for hawker
why did you use ipsc derived mscs and no
other ms
sources okay this is a good question so
as i mentioned before one of the
preliminary story
that we did was was the selection of the
the cell source
so we we did three studies in parallel
uh using adipose derivements and
chymostem cells
bone marrow stromal cells and ipsc the
right messenger stem cells
but what we saw in in this experiment is
that
using the ipsc i was able to get
the highest yield of exosome uh under
our specific conditions so but it's good
that
you know this is a good example for our
customers so
um we were we were not pursuing a
particular
sales source we're able to use one and
show the customer that
with our conditions they can get you
know good
amount of exercise and also they can
follow
our our protocols
okay great uh is there a solution to
just harvest the supernatant with the
exosomes
already uh that one is for you okay
um i would say that usually for the
secret cell derived product
we could use fibrocell disk and packed
bed bioreactors which offer a nice
opportunity to make easier
the collection of the final product but
with
exosomes it's there is some some
difficulties
related to the medium composition and
the presence of the
exogenous exosomes in the medium
as we have mentioned in the first
question um
and so as previously discussed there is
no perfect composition for the moment
to promote in the main time the cell
proliferation
very efficiently without exogenous
ev contamination so we have to shift
switch the medium for ev collection
medium which is not so easy
with the packed bed by reactors
and which isolation system do you see
best suited for the future to scale up
the process
if i could continue perhaps i could say
that currently
there is no perfect and standard
isolation methods
usually researchers use a combination of
two techniques
to improve the purity and reach the
balance between
specificity and efficiency
an interesting combination in term of
scale ups could be the
use of the tangential flow filtration
first
followed by a more specific affinity
capture
step
yeah if i can say something that there
is no standardized method that we can
use
right now in the market so the best
thing that we can do is to combine both
in order to get the high peers of
populations
okay thank you um the next question i
guess
both of you can answer or i have a
different answer it's uh which
microcarrier did you use for your
experiment
uh yeah perhaps i can start um
it exists really a large variety of
different carriers on the market and
on the publication there is no a perfect
solution for
msc so there is large different
possibilities
some carriers could be macroporous
microporous
non-porous some present some surface
coating
such as collagen or synthamax coated
carrier to improve the cell adhesion so
it's not so easy to select
i think it depends on the cell type you
use
but also on the medium composition
for example when you use synthetic
medium or medium which are reduced in
fps you could
you could use surface coated
carriers in order to improve the cell
initial
adhesion on the carriers so what that's
what we have done
for uh my part of the the
experiment and we have used the
synthemax coated carriers
yeah so i use the golem gold cutter so
they're good uh
in cell support especially at the
beginning of the of the spring and when
we
we need the discuss attached as soon as
possible
over the surface and
avoid lag in our in our culture so
and with the calling code cards are good
microcurrents to
address uh to avoid certain limitations
of cell
cell attachment at the beginning of the
spring
okay uh at the beginning of the
presentation you mentioned the
increasing
interest and clinical treatments can you
give an example of oxygen used in
clinical treatment
well um so when i was uh
of course my preliminary studies the the
story that had been done
and then preparing this uh webinar so i
have been
reviewing of course a lot of literature
but then i found
that you know right now as as everybody
saw in the presentation that there are
many
products in the market and many many
clinical trials going on
right now but i would like to highlight
one paper
um the paper
is from professor gible and collaborator
from the university of essen
in in germany and they use
mesenchyma stem cells derivation as a
novel tool to trade therapy
refractory graft versus host tissue
uh because mesenchymal stem cells are
considered immunomodulating
uh cells i mean this this is for the
people who are not
very familiar with that is when you
implant
uh a tissue from one person and then
uh the the the hospice will reject this
uh allergenic cell that you are
implanting in in this patient
normally what people use is corticoids
in order to reduce inflammation
a lot of the immune system to accept the
the new cells
but basically they have been they use
here exosomes with good results
i i mean if people want to read more
information about that i would be happy
to share the
paper but uh basically at the end they
found that they reviews
the colorado side reactions uh
due to that disease and yeah they
explained that
they did that in one patient and they
found good
uh you know they conclude that the
exosomes
may be a great potential to to to reduce
inflammation
as a skin disease i think this is one
example but again
right now we have many options in the
market many clinical trials going on
this is a new field
and i have hope that uh many limitations
associated with the cell therapy can be
addressed
using the exosomes uh or cell free
therapy as
uh people know uh this field right now
there are really a lot of questions on
the list
but i think we have time for one last
question
hopefully i will give this one to you
how to reduce the leg phase often
observed after seeding in a bioreactor
all right it's a good question um
especially for people which
are perhaps afraid by the transition
from 2d
to 3d culture
so of course the
[Music]
the the quality of the initial cell
is very important you have of course to
use self
uh very young the successive passage
especially for
mscs could induce progressive senescence
and
changing the phenotype and decreasing
the proliferation
rate um the courier selection
is also important uh you have we have
already discussed this point
uh but also other parameters like the
initial self-seeding density
and the so-called cell to beat ratio
so it's really important to to optimize
those parameters with your system
uh usually we use a ratio of three to
five cells per beat it's recommended but
you you have to optimize this case by
case and test
with yourself and your medium um
another uh recommendation could be to
to really stop the agitation during the
first hours
just after the seeding of the cells and
work also with the reduced
working volumes during this short period
period it could
help the adhesion of the cells to the
to the carriers and then a better start
of the proliferation a faster
start um this is
an interesting parameters uh yeah
okay thank you both for all the detailed
answers for all the questions that we
didn't answer yet
uh we will get in contact with you soon
and write you an email
with an answer to your questions thank
you all for listening and enjoy the rest
of the day
bye